si elle y est halal bonjour merci de
répondre à nos questions sur rt france
moderne a aujourd'hui pfizer spoutnik
weyer sans oublier sanofi sinovac ou
astrazeneca de quel oeil
est-ce que vous suivez toutes ces
évolutions espoirs prudence d'abord d'un
des professionnels comme médecin
réanimateur
je suis et scientifique je suis en
première ligne sur ces questions là et
dont ce sont de véritables avancées donc
c'est très clair ce sont de bonnes
nouvelles sur le plan vaccinal des
progrès considérables ont été faits on a
la chance d'avoir plusieurs types de
vaccins différents qui se profile est
certain qu'ils devraient dont ceux que
vous avez cités qui devrait être
commercialisé dans les toutes prochaines
semaines
ça c'est un élément important et c'est
un point positif dans cette lutte contre
la pandémie sur la mise à disponibilité
du vaccin et l'accès à cette mesure
préventive fondamentale il me semble que
la stratégie doit être planétaire parce
qu'on a affaire à une pandémie est donc
l'om est ce doit être en mesure de
proposer une stratégie sanitaire de
vaccination sur l'ensemble de la planète
et il me semble qu'il appartiendra
nations unies d'en assurer ensuite
l'organisation équitable de façon à ce
qu'on ne se trouve pas en effet dans une
situation où les pays des plus riches
ceux qui ont habituellement le plus
facilement accès aux soins seraient à
nouveau priorisés par rapport aux pays
les plus pauvres
il n'y aura pas de victoire contre la
pandémie
si cette victoire n'est pas plat des
terres et donc il est fondamental que la
france joue son rôle pour ainsi dès
cette démarche internationale
il faut éviter tomber dans des démarches
purement nationale et au delà de cette
course au vaccin est ce que ce n'est pas
une course au communiqué puisque ces
résultats ne sont pas validés ça fait
rare de ma part pour l'instant par par
des publications scientifiques opération
de communication une véritable avancée
alors
alors d'abord ce sont de véritables
d'avancé parce que d'ailleurs encore une
fois il y a de la matière scientifique
bien sûr ce sont des résultats
préliminaires cela veut donc dire qu'il
faut attendre les résultats définitifs
pour connaître précisément les faits de
ces vaccins pourquoi alors ce sont bien
évidemment bien sûr ce sont des coûts de
communication et ses coûts de
communication sont des femmes politiques
dans certains cas mais aussi sur le plan
scientifique et sur le plan sociétal
une façon de donner un peu d'eux
d'espoir encore une fois à tout le monde
tous nos concitoyens sur l'arrivée
prochaine d'un vaccin
c'est une quelque chose qui devient de
plus en plus une réalité et qui est de
moins en moins de la science fiction
vous avez parlé de l'onu de l'om est ce
vous avez dit aussi qu'il ya des formes
politiques justement parlant de
politique il ya des politiques après ces
annonces dans des laboratoires présumé
donc d'efficacité de vaccins anti
qu'ovide les politiques ont lancé l'idée
d'une vaccination obligatoire
bonne ou mauvaise idée quels risques
réels c'est une très mauvaise idée
encore une fois je crois que il ya pour
moi un certain nombre de critères de
réussite de la stratégie vaccinale le
premier c'est qu'elle ne soit pas
obligatoire cette vaccination parce que
encore une fois la rendre obligatoire au
raid aux effets des faces le premier
c'est que la graverie la suspicion
autour de ce vaccin est et de ce tout se
conclut tistes qui promeuvent le lobby
pharmaceutique donc il ne faut pas
prendre avec cités sont obligatoires
d'une part de pour cette raison-là
deuxièmement parce qu'il faut être
réaliste il ne sera pas possible de
vacciner 60 millions de français en 2021
même sur le souhaitez donc on doit pas
rendre obligatoire une vaccination alors
même qu'on sait qu'on ne sera pas
capable de l'assuré pour tout le monde
donc c'est une très bonne visite et
qu'elle doit être obligatoire
deuxièmement le vaccin doit être gratuit
pour pouvoir être accessible par tout le
monde et que personne n'ait à ne pas se
vacciner pour des raisons financières
enfin troisièmement le cette vaccination
je le répète elle doit être orchestrée
au niveau international sinon elles
risquent d'échouer si il n'ya pas
d'animation et de coordination
internationale pour cette vaccination
justement par rapport à cette
vaccination selon un récent sondage
ipsos 54 % des français seraient prêts à
se faire vacciner contre moyenne de 73 %
tous pays confondus
comment est ce que vous expliquez cette
défiance des français pour la défiance
des français contre les vaccins en
général n'est malheureusement pas
récente
ça fait plus plus une dizaine d'années
maintenant que l'on observe une
réticence à la vaccination à la
vaccination contre la rougeole par
exemple ce qui a valu des épidémies de
rougeole reste en france et donc elle
est liée aux nécessités d'améliorer la
transparence autour de la vaccination de
d'avoir une démarche très pédagogique et
non pas coercitive de plus tôt expliqué
les raisons pour lesquelles il faut se
faire vacciner
plutôt que de rendre la vaccination
obligatoire la vaccination elle doit
être gratuite parce que c'est une mesure
de prévention primaire et ces éléments
là sont importants pour rassurer les
citoyens et pour leur donner envie de
répondre positivement à une stratégie
vaccinale
enfin vous savez il faut vraiment
prendre en compte le fait que la le
positionnement de chacun par rapport au
vaccin va dépendre de la situation
sanitaire
mamour le vaccin sera réellement
disponible si on est en pleine accalmie
autrement dit s'il n'ya vraiment on est
sortis complètement de la deuxième vague
qu'on va retrouver une vie à peu près
normale
il est probable que cette réticence à la
vaccination soit plus grande que si on
est toujours sous la menace d'une
troisième vague aussi voire plus forte
que la deuxième vague comptes et être en
train de subir actuellement
tous ces éléments sont en cours merci
djillali annane d'avoir répondu à nos
questions je rappelle que vous êtes le
chef du service de réanimation de
l'hôpital
raymond poincaré à garches dans le val
d'oise